yo what's up guys my name is Samuel EADS
welcome to this week's winners on a
Wednesday I got the most crazy guest on
the show this dude started nothin in
South Africa
he's now a multi-millionaire I'm really
honored to have helped him in property
in the UK but I tell you something you
need to watch this whole interview start
to finish
welcome on bonus so welcome to this
week's winners on a Wednesday are non
bonus listen dude when we met you
already a winner
you were like multi-millionaire killing
it in business killing it in property
and and then you came to me because you
wanted me to help you invest in the UK
specifically and you've achieved like
literally so much which we're gonna
unfold in this interview but let me just
ask you a question why did you come to
me in terms of UK property investment
great question first of all thanks for
inviting me excited to be here several
things first of all one of the key
things that I've learned on my journey
to achieving success is choose your
mentors choose your teachers choose the
people you surround yourself with choose
them carefully yeah and so doing a lot
of research looking online and obviously
speaking to friends of mine who are very
successful businessmen in the UK all the
roads said Samuel Leeds everyone said
Samuel now the funny thing is we met
2015 ish and I met you we had a great
connection we spoke and the funny thing
is now we close circle we're sitting
here at this table talking about you
know expanding my property portfolio my
property investments into the UK and so
I chose the UK because I've four years I
know it's the hottest place to buy
property in Europe and currently living
in Holland but obviously I'm in the UK a
lot and so I wanted to know that I
wanted to work with people that are
living and doing it yes because there's
so many people out there who talk a good
story but they don't eat their own
cooking I wanted someone who eats their
own cooking and everyone people that I
trust at the deepest level everyone said
you've got to talk to salmon you do
serious due diligence like although
you're very important even fast-paced
when you do
sometimes you're also very careful and a
new Jewish as well oh yeah totally and
we hate losing money right so I'm really
honored that you've come to me I know
you've shared the stage of people like
Robert Kiyosaki you spoke him up
alongside Robert Kiyosaki yeah many
times multiple times share the stage
with Robert with his wife Kim what an
amazing woman several times had that
privilege to have that pleasure
he's been represented by the same
company that promote Tony Robbins Sir
Richard Branson like serious name so
when you reached out to me on the
property front you know others already
knew who you were in fact I'd heard you
speak on stage so I was really I was
really humbled and honored that you
reached out to me and we were put in
touch by Marcos de Maria yeah and then
now the fact that now we're sitting well
now we're in my dining room we've been
sat in my living room
picking up the phone doing deals we're
working on some really juicy part yeah
we actually found a really cool project
that we're gonna be looking at next week
yes and we're looking at development
we're looking at some smaller stuff some
bigger stuff so why don't you just talk
to me a little bit about your backstory
how you got started in property in the
first it's funny story because you know
a lot of people know me as a businessman
I've made serious serious money in
business built businesses sold
businesses built businesses sold
businesses but growing up as a kid my
late father would actually invite my mum
to meet him at a property that he just
purchased and I remember being dragged
along at the time I might have been 8 9
years old maybe 10 years old I've been
dragged along with my mom to meet my
father at a property that he just
purchased and I remember walking to all
these properties and going up the
driveway I mean this is back in South
Africa and my mum holding my hand
confronting my father with why did you
buy this dump that was that that was the
theme of all these conversations at
first glimps my mom would walk up see
these houses and the first thing she'd
come up come out of her mouth she would
say why did you invest in this dump yeah
why did you buy this
but you dad knew that the Oggy house is
make the most money well that's the
thing now I'm an eight nine year old kid
right what do I know all I hear is why
did you buy this dump and my father's
calming her down don't worry it's good
and then I remember you know two three
months later going back to the same home
and my mom being totally shocked
looking at the property not believing
the transformation that my father had
created so he'd buy these dumps
refurbish them rebuild them design them
and flip them or rent them and so that
was my first introduction into real
estate the same stuff that we're doing
now exactly but this is all this has
gone on for hundreds and hundreds of
years yeah nice yeah so your dad's been
successful in property was he was he
wealthy so my dad did very well through
property so you know my background story
you probably you know a little bit more
about this so I I left my I left South
Africa when I was a kid I moved on I
moved to Israel my parents were divorced
when I was about 12 I lost contact with
my father when I was 14 I saw him one
more time for a short visit when he came
to visit from South Africa to Israel
when he was six when I was 16 but I kind
of lost all contact with him from the
age of 14 hmm
I did see him one more time when I was
25 that's when I buried him so my father
had done well through property but I
didn't have that connection with him
growing up mm-hmm
I know that now you are very successful
in business but you're also a great
father and I know you spend a lot of
time with your kid Joshua yeah which is
great because a lot of people that do
well in business there's sofa I don't
know you dad story but they're so
focused on business that they sometimes
lack in other areas so it's great to see
that you've almost flipped the cards on
that and I think this was one of the
drivers that that that also bring me to
this table right because I want to
become a successful I can to be a
positive role model for my son yeah I
mean every every single person is a role
model for someone and either you're a
role model what to be or what not to be
mm-hmm and I don't want to be a role
model what not to be yeah and my father
who who bless him and I'm at peace with
the whole scenario and the story he
showed me exactly what not to be yeah
and that's why for me having a son who I
love dearly who's a big part of my life
I want to show him what to be yeah
because we go into business to provide
for our families to be the best version
of ourselves for our families
but sometimes we the main thing doesn't
become the main thing anymore yeah and
we lose sight of why we started in the
first place aleut Li so that was South
Africa how how did you end up moving in
because I know you've you've lived in
lots of different countries yes so talk
to me a little bit about give me a
summary of your story because it's so
interesting in short and sweet you know
born in South Africa grew up in
Johannesburg during the apartheid years
my family Jewish you know we grew up
without any color without religion
we had South Africans we actually had a
Zulu family who would became my family
and during the apartheid years it became
very tough to maintain that kind of
lifestyle I didn't grow up with color I
didn't grow up with with religion I
didn't grow up with it we were all the
same yeah white black pink green we were
all the same and my parents at a young
age decided that better to relocate I
moved to Israel lived in Israel for a
few years I spent some time in the
military where I learned some very
powerful lessons you know how to be
focused how to be disciplined and I see
that in your business how to work as a
team yeah but you run your business
sometimes I mean you've got a massive
heart but you do run it very disciplined
almost military like yeah and even when
you train when I see you on stage it's
it's so unique and the reason why I
guess that comes out is because I've
seen how to get the best out of people
yeah and people need guidance I need
guidance I need someone to say to me
like we did today right we sat down no
questions open the laptop let's look for
properties let's go online boom boom
boom boom and it's sometimes what people
need because I feel that the comfortable
creates an uncomfortable life and so if
you want to push yourself if I want to
push myself I've got to have structure
around me I need someone literally
saying okay open the laptop pick up the
phone it's called the agent let's do
this and that's yes I guess one of the
reasons I am successful today he said I
always had people holding me accountable
yeah and people are afraid of
accountability but yeah I've seen the
human spirit and I know what the human
spirit can do human beings can do great
things when they have a support
environment when they have
accountability around them we're never
structure when they have tools that
human spirit can be phenomenal but I see
human beings sometimes doing terrible
yeah you know cuz you know they're lazy
yeah so when you moved to Israel to
Israel in the military yeah how long did
you serve three years three years four
years mandatory and then and then you
ended middle or lessons flat you ended
up in Holland in the Netherlands set up
a successful business but what was your
first business okay actually my first
business I started when I was 11 years
old selling toys from my uncle's toy
store two kids at school so you're just
one of these people though you're just
one of these it's entrepreneurial people
and that's why you're very interesting
winners Wednesday cuz a lot of people
that come on windows Wednesday they met
me as an employee and then they became
financially free you met me as a
multi-millionaire yeah the deals that
we've done in the UK will still make you
financially free again but you've
already done it a hundred times over
yeah so it's a isn't it but still I
thought you definitely need to be on the
winners Wednesday show so how did you
end up doing business in the Netherlands
was that back a brand new us very simple
I had a uk-based company which I sold
and I exited that company I made a lot
of cash and I met a gentleman living in
the UK investing in property in the
Netherlands and I was sitting around you
know I had a good exit and he kept on
saying to me why don't you come to
Holland look at some property deals it's
very interesting come come come and I
was like no no no and I remember saying
to him at one point I said - he was he
was pushing me come to Holland come to
Holland and I threw out my last
objection and that was well how long's
the flight and he said 45 minutes I said
okay I'm coming yeah it was a bad
objection yeah because I was hoping he
was gonna say like four hours or five
hours right I mean this is in my late
twenties and never been to Holland
before and so he says like a 45 50
minute flight I was like a bus yeah
exactly we have people coming from from
from the Netherlands to our UK events
all the time
you've seen them it's a nothing journey
yeah yeah
and so I moved to Holland bought some
property there actually I have a seven
figure property portfolio in Holland I
am big in the service departments space
so I have quite a few apartments and
buildings in Amsterdam but I'm also
serviced accommodation in Amsterdam yeah
it's funny because the principles that
that we use property for that we are we
have international students all the time
it's the same like if you're investing
in America if you're investing in
Holland Europe England the principles
are the same and that's it's so
interesting because sometimes people
think I mean I am a UK property investor
and you know I'm UK on British I know
the UK market but that doesn't mean that
the strategies can't be applied
elsewhere people love to come over
excuses you know all this doesn't work
in my area this doesn't work in my
country actually it probably does and if
it doesn't you just need to tweak it a
little bit yeah you've always got to be
creative yeah you've always got to be
fluid so I mean tell me about your
portfolio then so you you sold a
business will you invested the money
into the Netherlands property yeah so
one of the bigger mistakes that I made
is I moved to Holland I had a lot of
cash because I sold one of my companies
and I took it and I throw it all into
property yes and then when the more I'm
working yeah and what year was this this
is 2008 so you threw all your money into
property in two years 2000 to 2007 2004
it tanked threw everything into property
and then a tanked now because I was
focusing primarily on serviced
apartments so obviously tourism dropped
not only did tourism drop but the prices
per night dropped yeah so I had a lot of
stones I had a lot of property but I had
no cash right and so then my mind said
at that moment was not to sell because
that's what most people would have done
major mistake major mistake and I
realized that I just had to ride the
wave yeah
my mindset was if I could get to
2012-2013 I will be okay yeah and I did
my properties did okay they generated
cash flow I actually became financially
free through that property investment
portfolio that those investments that I
did because when I saw my business I'd
cash but I wasn't financially free yeah
and so I invested into property in that
created my financial freedom for me but
the thing is it's really good less than
that and we can't skip over it because
you bought properties and then the
market crashed normally in a recession
rents go up because everybody because
everybody everybody has to rent because
they can't buy yes but in your case you
had a double whammy negative blow
because not only did the property prices
drop but because it was serviced
apartments and tourism was struggling
and everything your cash flow drops
that's like terrible most people would
have sold I'm gonna take in the hit but
you said no I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna hold it out knowing that
ultimately you gonna win and the reason
for that being is because I knew there
would be a recovery yeah of course I
look at history history always repeats
itself I said this I say there's a big
believer history will always repeat
itself and so I knew that there was
gonna be a turning point I look at other
great property investors people who have
done really well in property sometimes
they've been in a situation where their
property portfolio is down millions tens
of millions hundreds of millions and
then their philosophies let me just ride
the wave yeah let me just ride this wave
three four five years as long as I don't
sell I'll come out of it and that's what
happened to me and I've done really well
with that
that's so so exciting so when your
properties went up because I know a few
years later they suddenly shot up in
value the rents went good again how did
you feel well amazing actually it's
funny because I just I I think I told
you a little bit earlier I have a
property one of my properties I have a
few one of my properties which is a
building four floors with a shop at the
bottom I bought this property about six
years ago I bought it for just over five
hundred thousand just put it over five
hundred thousand and cashflow was
positive I have a loan I had a loan on
this for about three hundred forty
thousand from a bank and I got an offer
on this property that I just I decided
to take because it was just so good and
so I sold this property for a million
and I walked away with a really nice
profit and what happens you bought that
property for how much well just over
five hundred thousand but my mortgage on
home was just over three hundred and
that one this was 2014 14 so he bought
it in 2014 yeah and then you saw it last
year 2019 you bought it for just over
five hundred thousand and you sold it
for a million yeah that's nice yeah my
loan was just over three hundred K right
so I had a business partner in this this
deal but so I've done a really well in
property and I'm a big believer in
property and I think that a lot of
people who can create income business
owners business leaders even people who
are in in a job if you have the capacity
to create money that's not enough you
become one-dimensional you have to be
able to put the money in a place that it
can create more money yeah a lot of
people know how to make money they don't
know how to grow their money yeah yeah
so it's almost like I mean my friend
James Sinclair talked about this is fast
pound slow pound so fast power might be
a business it's gonna create fast cash
and then that cash you then dump into
properties smartly which is then going
to give you slow pound now the first
pound might be I know a lot of my
students they do deal sourcing so
they're packaged and they sell deals
don't make 3,000 pound every time they
sell a deal and they'll sell five deals
a week and they're making a serious cash
flow all they'll do rent to rent
serviced accommodation like serious cash
flow but then with that cash they'll
then put it over here into more slow
long term campus of appreciation and the
tutee goes it's like riding a boat with
two oars and I think that's where true
financial freedom and wealth building
comes from and well that's the key word
wealth is created over time yeah and and
I think this is this is so important to
understand achieving financial freedom
is not that difficult
do you see my FF challenges you can do
it in no time yeah and this is this is
what I love about it is really it's a
mythbuster-y people think you've got to
dedicate three four five ten years to
achieve financial freedom but if you
break it down and you look at the
actions that are necessary to take you
can achieve financial freedom relatively
fast I mean they're doing what you doing
is insane
yeah that's not normal yeah it's not
normal right but you can but six months
is very doable Oh totally three months
is doable it is if you focused and
committed and if you have the right
knowledge and education absolutely and
this is as funny you say there because a
lot of people are not
willing to educate themselves and and I
say if you're not willing to educate
yourself life will educate you yeah and
so I dropped out of school I didn't
finish school you know I went to help my
mom put food on the table put clothes on
my younger sister baby brother you know
my dad left as I said but one thing I
knew I knew that I had to educate myself
and so I picked up the books and you
know you mentioned I shared the stage
with Robert Kiyosaki what was funny is
that one of the first books that really
got me on the path to achieving
financial freedom and start thinking
different outside of the 9:00 to 5:00
9:00 to 5:00 until you're 65 right one
of the first books that got me on that
path was Rich Dad Poor Dad yeah and I
know you're a big fan as well right of
course so when I shared the stage with
Robert Kiyosaki I actually shared with
him that I would never in a million
years would have believed that after
reading his book being inspired by his
book building what I've built creating
financial freedom investing in property
in and built what I've built ended up
sharing the stage with him that wouldn't
I would never ever
yeah like talking teaching the same
audience and your honor you've also
shared the stage and taught along so
people like Les Brown yes yeah you've
done some amazing things why did you
choose the UK you've done very
successfully in the Netherlands but the
Netherlands is a great place to invest
if you know what you're doing you've
invested your at least your dad invested
in South Africa what you've seen
everywhere in the world you're a global
business man could travel the world yes
you have businesses you do you do
training all across the world why did
you even though you don't live in the UK
why have you come to not only come to me
but why did you choose the UK as a
nation to invest in property great
question so first of all I believe that
the center of the world is London like
you said I travel the world I do 90
trips around the world in a year yeah
and so for me London is the center of
the world everything follows London in
my opinion what about what about New
York again New York is America London is
the world if you setting up an office if
you setting up an office you want to set
up an office in London if you have a if
you have an office in New York you're
not going to capture all of Europe you
know
capture Asia Asia follows London more
now today then it does New York
interesting very interesting see
people's comments on that because I'm
sure that people some people would agree
some people wouldn't be so totally yeah
because it's a little bit of a
subjective thing well I agree that's why
I have my offices in I have friends who
are I have a friend who's a billionaire
billionaire with a be he's a hotel he
owns hotels all over the world
I've got other friends who are in big
construction businesses and they all
raise finance from London they fly into
the UK they sit in Mayfair they sit they
sit in that area and that's where they
meet the finance houses so if anyone's
listening to this he's from London you
have no excuses listen I have never I
teach all over the world I train all
over the world I have never met any of
my students that live in the UK and have
a lot of students from the UK I've got a
lot of people that I work with in
Belgium Germany you know Holland rich
countries right first world country I've
never met any student come to me and say
to me
Arnon if I could just get to Uganda my
financial life would be okay I mean if
you're not doing financially well in the
UK
living in the UK Belgium Holland Germany
first of all country if you're not doing
well financially living in any of these
countries there's something you don't
know yeah well you suck Oh totally I
mean like but it's easier to get rich in
a country like this then not especially
if you moan about it well then you suck
yeah and when the banks are giving out
pretty much free money money if you
can't in a first world country when the
banks are giving out pretty much free
money 3% if you can't set up a business
or buy properties that are going to make
profit and you can't raised a little bit
of finance that you need then you say
any on the water you dead in the water
yeah you know people say things like you
know oh I haven't got any money
great raise the money there hope I don't
have to do that well learn to do that
sure pick up a book that you know I've
got a great friend
I was recently visiting Israel
over the new year and I spent time with
some really good friends of mine from
the past and and in they look at me
today and they say I want some how did
you do it because yeah because they know
where I grew up was I was that I was the
poorest kid in the block right I was the
first kid in the neighborhood I was
hungry I was determined but you know my
mom couldn't put me through a fancy
university or college you know I didn't
have any of that stuff but today I'm the
wealthiest yeah and and so it's very
funny it's very contradictive based on
where we came up from you know one would
have bet on me right that was me man I
was always the the person that was like
the silly one the least intelligent the
worst academic lady getting into trouble
and now on the wealthiest person in my
family exactly and so my friends they
say I want some right in the beginning
their conversations with me were you had
luck yeah you had you were lucky
yeah and what I said to them you didn't
see the days when I was actually
investing in property in Holland where I
would walk in the rain with an umbrella
that was broken peanut falls back you
know going from viewing to viewing to
viewing I used to view six seven eight
properties a day day in day out day in
doubt for weeks on end until I didn't
inside the property that I like right
and then nobody sees that so the first
phrase from their perspective was oh you
had luck yeah now they become more
intelligent
now they understanding that wait a
minute there's something more than luck
here and and and now they say I want
some and they say how did you do it and
I say to them well why don't you stop
reading a book and I say what I'm like
yeah read a book go to a seminar take a
course and I've even directed my friends
to buying Rich Dad Poor Dad Think and
Grow Rich Napoleon Hill they go out they
get excited they buy the book
they haven't read nothing and so when
you say you know how can if you live in
the UK how come you're not successful or
how come people don't you know achieve
financial freedom is because I think a
lot of people don't have enough pain
people are way too comfortable yeah and
so for me
achieving financial freedom investing
and continuing to invest and expand my
property activities in the UK is that I
have pain I will not
myself to not live my full potential
yeah I could easily switch off tomorrow
but I don't want to rot yeah people will
message you though on Facebook and say
I've got this property question or can
you help me with this but then they
won't take a four-hour trip to attend
the program it's crazy
you know so it's like well if you really
wanted to know the answers if you really
wanted to get trained up I mean come on
man what is what is what's wrong what's
going on and I see that all the time my
belief is when commitment and
preparation meet success will follow
yeah and that's one thing I've always
been committed and I've always been
willing to be prepared yeah and that's
why success has followed so what's next
I know where do some crazy good deals
with books a lot of viewings just today
yeah we're looking at we're also looking
at a some land to develop as well work
with my team which is which is really
exciting what's your plan in 2020 well
for me I have to acquire properties in
the UK we're looking at a few deals
we've got a few things in the pipeline
we got a few viewings lined up already
it's about acquisitions now it's about
you know just making it happen and
expanding the property activities that I
really do in Europe to the UK yeah it's
really cool having you as well because I
know you you you do some teaching at our
cross courses which is incredible
because the thing is a lot of people
have said to me you know Samuel we want
to hear different perspectives we want
to get different people up also I
physically can't go to every single
training event that we've run but about
having people that I trust enough to be
able to share the stage with me or teach
something on my stage with my audience
it's like they need to be number one
they need to have a really big heart you
know they need to be there for the right
reasons number two they're got to really
know their stuff they've got a really
know that industry being they're done
they got the t-shirt and number three is
they need to be a great communicator yes
and a good friend
now you tick all those boxes so when you
when I rank you up and said dude how
would you feel about coming down to the
crash course and sharing in you and you
came down and you said
everybody loved that got results from it
went and got deals I mean it was a great
feeling for me but why when you're
financially free and you make your money
doing property this is a question I get
asked all the time I'm now gonna ask you
the question why would you bother to
spend the time teaching other people to
do it rather than just focusing solely
on investing and making money in
property yourself what would you share I
think I think it's one of the most
important questions you just asked days
why would I do it you know financially I
don't need to do it I don't need to be
here you know I've worked hard enough as
you can see that I don't need to be
doing this financially but one of the
most impactful days of my life is the
day off that I teach and why is that
because the day after I teach I get all
the messages yeah I get the messages on
Facebook I get the messages on Instagram
and the messages are like this are
annoying I just wanted to thank you
because you gave me a second second
opportunity I get I get messages with
people saying to me are known before the
program I wanted to commit suicide and
now you've given me a new shot a new
opportunity a new perspective and for me
those messages no money in the world can
buy them yeah and that's what I do
that's what that's what gets me so
fulfilled in and gets me going and
that's why I love doing it yeah because
listen I wasn't always you know to be
blessed as I am financially you know I
came from a rough background and I
remember there were times where I was on
my knees you know looking up and asking
the big man to help me out you know and
and I remember making commitments and
and and even saying to myself you know
if if if I could just get myself out of
this situation and come good financially
I promise that when I become successful
I will help people yeah so I feel like
today I'm just fulfilling the mission
I'm just you know you know giving back
and fulfilling my word and I believe if
you're successful it's your obligation
to send the elevator back down yeah I
mean what else would I be doing with my
life right well what I mean how much TV
can you watch how much football games
can you watch how much traveling can you
do it's all good
but I have a greater sense of
responsibility of helping more people
because my belief is [ __ ] if I could do
it you know didn't come from a rich
background I moved from South Africa to
Israel I was like a refugee no money
I couldn't barely speak the language my
mom was struggling you know my mom would
work two three jobs a day you know so if
I could sit here at this table and have
these successes if I can do it anyone
can do it like really anyone can do it
yeah and so and I think that that just
comes to him and that spills out of use
out of you and some people might not be
able to relate to that some of them I
think
man if I became financially free I just
going to live on a beach somewhere but
until you become financially free you
realize that actually success is good
but significance tastes a lot better and
and I know that you I mean financially
in a position where you don't need to be
on this podcast you don't need to be
coming to the crash course with me
tomorrow but you don't need to do that
but I know I get it it gives you a kick
in the exact same way it gives me a kick
and I don't even take a salary from from
the training business like I do it
because I love it so much however of
course it does open up doors because
it's nice when people know who you are
they say that in business you want
people it's all about who you know
but actually it's who knows you yeah it
is
and I think that's so powerful so from a
branding perspective being on stage
coming on podcasts even being here on
winners Wednesday it's a good thing so
why did you want to come on windows
Wednesday because I know we spoke about
you were like dude I'd love to be on the
show I I think one of the key things for
me is I always want to be inspired and I
was inspired by you and your mission and
in your the amount of people you touch I
know you've got a list next to your bed
of all the people that have achieved
financial freedom these are things that
talk to me once you go through the toy
phase once you go through the beachbum
phase and you know once you've gone
through that phase you look at life at
least I did I looked at life and I said
okay now what
mmm when I saw my first company and I
got serious money now that stuff diggers
yeah when I when I looked at my bank
account when I when I saw my first
business and I looked at that bank
account I saw that that number in my
bank account I was excited and I was
over the moon for exactly 23 seconds and
then I looked at then I said now what
yeah and so I did the beach thing I did
the travel thing but I believe that
there's so much more of us to give and
so I'm here to give like you are well
you know what I did the same thing when
I was completely financially free I went
to Africa I didn't challenge stuff I
climbed up Kilimanjaro I wrote an album
I learned to play the trumpet I joined a
band I travelled but it gets to a point
where it's like I want to impact people
yeah I don't just want to I don't just
want to go around exploring and
adventuring and taking and having fun I
want to actually impact people and leave
a legacy so it's great to see what you'd
do in I know this isn't the last time
you'll be on the show we'll be
documenting stuff we've got some crazy
exciting deals so if people come to a
property investors crash course is there
a chance that they might get to me
either
actually I hope they do yeah and I hope
they come up and shake my hand and share
with me why they there and what is their
pain why they have to achieve success
because for me it's not about just
showing up listening taking a few notes
and going home I want people to actually
take action and do something yeah you
know you know they say a little bit of
knowledge is a dangerous thing I don't
want them to have a little bit of
knowledge just come to the crash course
because they eat two days there I want
them to take this seriously because it's
what did you think when you first got a
lot of successful people coming to the
crash course some people have got
nothing yeah no money no credit other
people come and they've got money they
want to invest it what did you first
think like what was your experience when
you first came to the crash oh I was I
was I was surprised positively surprised
because on day one in the crash course
you share some really powerful tools for
anyone whether you're a startup whether
you're seasoned
how do source
really good deals and I was like is this
for real are you really giving all this
information away and it just showed me
that I was in the right place yeah
because I want to be with people that
are givers I don't want to be in an area
or in a space of takers because it's
like everything you learned the crash
course is just like every it's like my
brain and everything I've learned about
property over the last 10 12 years
condensed into two days I know the
remote I know we have advanced training
programs we have the Academy and things
like that but they say that the all
starts at the crash course and I really
believe it so for me it wasn't a seminar
was a do or not yeah because you know
people are rolling up their sleeves
getting down you know dirty picking up
the phone doing some really cool stuff
so for me like if anybody's listening to
this or watching this recording I say
don't even think twice I mean how can
you not get into property it's one of
property has created more millionaires
than any other asset class that exists
so if you're living in the UK if you're
living in Europe right now oh my
goodness how can you ignore property and
you think it's a good time to borrow
right now it for me the answer would be
absolutely yes and there's several
reasons for that is first of all if I
look at property in a hole I know that
the UK is not creating more land divorce
rates sky-high so if you're in a couple
and now you're getting divorced now you
haven't you need a new property right
yeah it's only one family turned into
two families exactly birthrate through
the roof and so you know one of the
biggest mistakes that my family made my
grandfather made many years ago grow you
know he lived in South Africa he had a
huge home in South Africa and he lived
there with with my grandma
his wife and his two daughters my mum
and my aunt and eventually when my mom
and her sister got married and left the
house my grandparents were left in this
big house and they realized they don't
need such a big house so they decided to
sell the property and they came to my
father property investor and they said
to him Victor we're gonna sell our house
what do you suggest we do with the money
we make with the money the profits that
and my dad said to them look whatever
you sell take about 10% of that money
and enjoy it
maybe travel see the world you know use
it for you and 90% of it reinvested into
property go out buy another four five
six properties and just rent it out and
they thought about it and they thought
about it and they sold the property and
they put all the money in the bank and
my grandparents have passed away
recently not too long ago but until the
day they they passed away they always
said one of the biggest mistakes that
they made was not listening to my father
that they didn't invest in property and
so for me the question is you know if
not now then when
and if not property then what and if not
you then who and so it's a phenomenal
time there's free money in the
marketplace yeah the banks are literally
saying to you here's money and the
bottom line is it's just a number it's
just straightforward numbers and stats
and this there's a massive shortage of
UK property and there's an
overpopulation of people so I'm excited
I'm looking forward to the deals that
we're doing together
what advice would you give to someone
that was considering booking onto the
property investors crash course come
play full out just be open and do
whatever it takes to win and and and get
uncomfortable get uncomfortable being
comfortable with getting uncomfortable
whether it's picking up the phone
speaking to an agent viewing a property
and and one more thing if you treat this
journey seriously read the books take
the courses go to every seminar you can
because staying in the space in this
energy in this environment pretty much
will guarantee success yeah one of the
reasons why I'm sitting here is because
I want to be around successful people
well 90% of success is just showing up
totally we know each other because we
showed up like we've been at the same
training courses together and I think
people miss that as well the networking
opportunities to get in a room so anyone
listening to this if you're on YouTube
go on the
description it will give a link to the
crash course you're listening on a
podcast go down to WWE - investors go to
UK get books onto the crash course if
you've been holding off now's the time
to do it you heard from the big man
himself on online thanks so much for
coming on the show you're awesome thank
you thank you for having me Sammy great
to be here I hope you enjoyed that video
I don't want you to subscribe to the
channel I don't want you to watch any
other videos I want you to do one thing
and that is get your tickets to the next
property investors crash course I want
you to be there so bad because I know
it's gonna change your financial life
forever so there's a free ticket right
here get booked on it's right here
listen I'm not going anywhere until you
click that button and book on do it and
do it right now
have you booked on yet I hope you have
it's still here go ahead time is running
out five four three two one get booked